what's going on everybody and welcome to
another deep learning in halite video in
this video what we're gonna be doing is
checking out the kind of results of
everything up to this point and then
talking about moving forward eventually
we have to stop this project because
it's just gonna take way too long for it
to become anything really truly
competitive but I still think it's a
really fun thing to just see how far you
can get from something like random so
let's talk about it so what's coming
here first and check out some of our
replays so this is from these are
replays from phase threes model again
all random at least to start so let me
bring in just the most recent replay
here then we got a bunch of replays but
I'll just bring in a couple I don't want
to but what has happened did I click
play I probably click to play ok at
least purple looks pretty good let's
speed up speed up the game rather
alright 10x okay purpley pink player
appears to do pretty darn well green
player does not look very good and light
green slash yellowy green player also
doesn't look very good okay so but again
these are all the same models so the
fact that we have that much of a delta
between the players is kind of weird the
next thing I wouldn't mind checking into
is like if you click on any one ship you
can see how much halite the ship has so
in this case this guy is got almost a
thousand he's got nine hundred and
eighty-seven how light he needs to
deposit that he's just wasting time here
this ship has zeros that's good 265 not
bad 853 needs to go deposit 330 maybe
should deposit but who knows let's check
these guys this guy is only one nine
seven six again needs to pause at 462
quite a bit 986 these
deposit 1000 you know green player if
green player would have just went and
deposited everything as the game was
coming to a close
green player would have won okay
so as you'll probably see in a lot of
replays from like top players at the end
all the ships just rushed their port
because it doesn't matter if your ship
sinks at the end so the quickest way is
just kind of suicide on your drop off
and so you we could incorporate this
into but into the game at the end or
something but the real big problem I
think is like even like halfway through
the game like when you shouldn't be
rushing the port necessarily we can
check five hundred bytes should deposit
nine seven two should deposit for sure
eight nine one should deposit fifty one
purple actually did pretty good so we're
not even gonna bother wasting time but
again here 846 these are deposit these
two guys are fine to continue along six
thirteen probably should deposit one
that was end deposit it so okay so I
think the thing I would like to do next
is probably force force ships to do that
this game actually looks pretty darn
good and also I know we're ending games
not very good like this in terms of
actual competition we would lose for
sure but in terms of an AI this trained
completely from random to learn to do
these things I just think this is the
coolest thing ever but that it's learned
to slowly pick up a light and slowly
drop it off I just think it's cool okay
so great so let me close and don't
forget like at the beginning randoms
like collect a hundred halite after
fifty turns so in theory maybe you could
extrapolate that to like say five
hundred turns and they collect a
thousand halite or something like that
but that doesn't appear like in this
case we're clearly way beyond that
number
and my guess would be you wouldn't
actually randomly collect a thousand
halite after that many turns but who
knows probably should check that out too
regardless definitely learning stuff
something anyways to get an edge and
some people have asked like how we won
last year in the ml bot well basically
we had a rule-based bot that was really
good and then we used deep learning on
the rule-based bot with some random
movements just like what we're doing
here and that was able to actually
outperform the rule-based spot it was
trained on and also get number 1 ml bot
and that's all we're doing here is we're
just slowly get edge edge edge and so on
so anyways but how could we fix at least
like some of these little problems that
we see I mean there's like two major
things that we can do here so you know
you want to make the decision do you
want to make a rule based bot and you
know just have a basically do you want
to add rules to your bot and then be
done with it or what you also could do
is you could add things to your buy and
then those things that you added add
them into training data so for example
do exactly what we did here with naive
navigate so we're trying to train the AI
to stop running into itself so we use
nav safe right but we threw that into
the training data we said hey by the way
use this as training data if we needed
to not move the way that we were
planning to move or whatever change the
training data make that the new input
data so maybe the model could learn to
not run into other friendly ships or
even enemy ships for that matter so
anyways so we can take that same thing
and apply it here with hurry up and go
deposit so what I'd like to do is let's
just close these and close out of here
let's first I'm gonna copy paste and
then we're gonna rename this to ml to
drop off then before I for to get let me
chain
and run game to drop off here so oops
hey man okay go away so we're gonna
replace this control H coming out here
paste replace all save great good work
team okay so now what we want to do is
I'm gonna get rid of these this comment
here I don't really need that first
we're gonna clean everything up no just
kidding so we'll come down here and
basically I'm trying to think of like
the cleanest way to do this but also the
quickest way to do this let's start by
throwing an if statement here if ship
dot how light amount is greater than or
equal to constants max underscore halite
/ - so if it's anything more than 500
how light hey we want to navigate to
that shipyard so how would we do this
well I vote we basically just do this
copy pasta done okay not really but
almost all we need to do is here rather
than you know do the position and all
that what we're gonna naively navigate
to is just me dot shipyard dot position
later if you had more drop-offs like if
we decide to add them later on to like
you know have rules to convert ships to
drop offs we could you know grab a sum
of one of the drop offs in the drop off
positions for whatever reason or pick a
random one or whatever but for now this
is what we want to do so again this
stuff here is all this this in theory we
can save this choice right we can
actually append that to the training
data right which we're doing right down
here now the other thing we need to do
is if
if this is the case do that l if this is
the case do that else do that and then
otherwise we're doing this silly mmm
this secondary this is not the smoothest
way to do this but just to save us from
running now you've navigate twice and
slowing down our code I'm gonna copy
this here paste okay so if random choice
I'm not and safe nav will do this and
then also if we make a model choice we
also want to run it through the safe nav
but this way we're not doubling up on
that safe nav also that would cause
confusion also why is this tab ugly are
you kidding me
what is he what does this what why is
this happening why does it keep
happening in then using spaces stop it
but why does that do that to me cool
okay we fixed that but why oh I don't
have to keep making that change that and
also why is that not default why is the
default tabs the heck out of here it is
probably gonna get angry I mean if I
don't fix these that's frustrating
okay good I think we're all set
alright so now when the ship has more
than 500 how light it will go and
naively navigate its way hopefully to
the shipyard let's see okay so what I'd
like to do is we're gonna take replays
make that replays old let's make a new
replays replays then we're gonna run
game Python
hopefully no errors come out okay making
it through some turns alright okay it
looks like we're good
see what happens um replays and I've
already closed the watch so let's go
ahead and open up halide dot IO watch
and I might I might have to like pause
or something like that come back when
we've got like a healthy number of
replays cuz not every replay is gonna be
very good and this AI is pretty bad when
like there isn't a good amount of halite
in the vicinity so so it's kind of by
chance if it's a good one or not but
anyways let's see how we did okay so
this one's not bad
these orange looks really good I don't
know how many ships orange ended up
producing we really like high ships but
we've got some seven ships over there it
looks like orange maxed out at five but
and there's a lot of jams happening here
I don't like that either my guess is I
wonder what those guys have in terms of
halite well we'll check them here in a
second like this poor soul locked in the
middle he's at zero though no big deal
any of these guys over 500 no any of
these guys over 500 hey no okay cool how
about green guy
don't worry while we're checking this
bt-dubs we got other games running in
the background 247 okay great okay let's
let's see what this next game did you
this one looks even worse gross more
chips than this and this should have
been a sort of been a pretty good game
because we've got a lot of a lot of good
highlight right here I wonder like I
wish we could stop the
I wish we could stop the back-and-forth
I wonder too like I wonder if you know
we'll be fine
if that what if we also said if ship dot
position equals needed shipyard dot
position copy/paste because we have a
lot of these ships that keep finding
their way on to so I just wonder like
what if we kick that ship off if it go
and so what if we make this I guess we
could make that an Elif but this is
getting sloppy but I'm really curious to
see if we get like constantly boot ships
off of the the the shipyard or any
drop-off location really so you can
continue doing stuff like this you also
could like I was saying before you could
add in some rule-based things like when
you know how to get head towards large
patches of highlighter you know
something like that and then continue
coaxing your AI to like learn the things
that you want it to learn also our
neural network is pretty darn basic
we're not really doing in a fancy AI at
all let's just see how this one did ohad
might even be worse at least they stay
the heck off of it these guys got lost
that's their problem
at least nobody's really hanging on the
shipyard we did definitely clear the
shipyard pretty well there
these guys don't really collect him very
much Hal ayat and again on these big
maps the AI has a really hard time
coming back out here I am curious though
like this guy show me the ship I'm kind
of surprised like none of these guys
have a good number of halite now so can
enhance I'm clicking on the ship okay I
don't know I don't know how much that
ship has but anyway not the best okay
let's check this game this looks like a
pretty high ship game Wow look at this
guy at the end whoo
I do like the get the hell off of the
shipyard code there Technica look man
that guy did good got seven ships and at
the very end 3,000 halite that's a
pretty good that's a pretty darn good
model but orange you know what what are
you doing over here you loser
whomp-whomp 74 34 6 I wonder if we
should change the value like uh you know
maybe maybe that's too big you know so
maybe maybe rather than / 2 / I don't
know 4 run a couple games anyway I'm
probably gonna stop it here unless I
happen to do something more with this
type of model it's just it's gonna take
a long time for it to eventually you
know to be anything decent I mean we've
played I shudder to think how many games
like hundreds of thousands of games for
sure and it just goes slow so I'm
starting to lose my patience but I do
think I mean I just I think that's super
cool like just to go from random
to like something like seeing games like
this where the players are pretty darn
good or even even this guy I mean he
sucked and he only has six ships but he
collected enough halite to produce
another ship I mean that's still pretty
cool is and again all from random like I
just think that's pretty crazy okay so
it looks like we have at least this one
game what do we choose divided by four I
think it was hmm that doesn't look to be
very good I don't think we want a div by
four that's a strange-looking game
though like what are these guys doing
this might just be dumb model not very
good guys you guys got that spot they're
like yeah this is this is the spot for
all the cool halite this one doesn't
look too good either
yeah like this guy didn't do anything he
produced some ships and then he just be
bopped around yeah so maybe some rules
to better find some halite they just
they clearly don't like to they don't
like to explore very much and then if
they do explore they wind up super lost
pretty often anyway okay so yeah I think
I'm going to stop it there pretty cool
like I said if I come up with something
else
oops I'm gonna try to open that I still
am not sure if I come up with something
else or you know some more cool things
happen I will be sure to update this and
just like I said before if anybody has
something that they really want to see
done we can I can implement that or if
you want to see you know if you've got
some sort of you know RL model or
something else that you want to see done
feel free to submit it and I'll be happy
to dedicate some processing power to it
but for now I think probably I'm going
to take my focus to the replay parsing
bot and see what I can do because there
is an abundance of high-quality data
there you don't have to pace pay play so
many games so I think that's kind of
that's probably where I'm going to take
my focus next and I think that's
probably what has the capability of
winning
halite or
at least doing pretty darn good this
year so that's what I'm gonna do but
this was a lot of fun really cool I mean
I just I just think that's cool
to go from purely random to performing
pretty well and actually I mean it did
pretty well before we forced it to go
and drop off at certain amounts we
definitely saw like how much waste there
was but at the same time I think that's
pretty darn impressive also hmm I just
thought about something I don't think I
ever so I did change the model okay yet
so this is running phase three okay
curiously I wouldn't mind checking model
two or thee which one was that I guess
it would be phase this phase two I don't
know I'm not sure which one it would be
I'm curious to see like how this one
might perform just run that really quick
and then come back to replays this
replay looks pretty good let's see see
how this one did so this is like the
last of the good ones
or rather the last of Phase three
which may or may not have actually been
a superior phase but again all of these
guys wow this guy's that's eight ships
so that's three extra ships and then he
kind of he doesn't do very good from
there but that's not bad not bad at all
okay how we doing over here it looks
like we should get at least one game
here pretty quickly let's just throw
this one up see how this one did hmm
there's one I looked too bad either
looks like he'll get at least six ships
this one's not the worst either
hmm yeah definitely would want to train
like a bunch of different models chaos
for example has a ton of built in models
that you could check out like mobile net
and inception and all that kind of stuff
I'll probably still tinker with that but
most likely those models are like
seriously overkill for what we're doing
here but I'd like to kind of poke into
it but just for the sake of keeping
things simple I think I'll price
probably leave you here but I still want
to see I want to see at least one more
game then I'll let you guys go while we
wait while we wait those are my old spot
our old members I have to bring up the
the new members okay so
did we get a new game here I think this
should be a new one hmm you know this
model might actually be a superior model
unfortunately to the first one it's hard
to say the other one definitely
collected more ships but this one I
don't know it seems to be a little more
reliable yeah that's tough I don't know
it might also just be like the most
recent model that we actually made for
whatever reason maybe it was over
trained under trained like who knows you
definitely want to play with it for
quite a while let's see any more games
let me throw this one in looks like this
was a big game yeah this one's not the
most beautiful see how many ships we got
looks like six was the max man that one
game where they had like eight ships
I've seen some games that have like ten
plus ships but that's like super rare so
this is that's cherry picking at that
point but anyway alright
so recent there we go got it updated
Jean yet
Jessica Hardesty tan Lee and Alvis taga
togs thank you guys very much for your
support
you guys okay so I think that's it for
now whoops that was the head of sponsor
if you didn't know how you sponsor you
can click on that beautiful blue [ __ ]
button down below otherwise that's it
for now
questions comments concerns suggestions
for improvements to the to the code or
if I've made a mistake there's high
probability I done goofed somewhere
along the way so feel free to leave all
that stuff down below continue the
conversation at discord dot gg so lash
cent X and I will see you guys next time